Welcome to Yotel.
Step inside with me as we take a tour of this trendy,...
...high-tech hotel in Times Square.
The whole design, the whole decor, is very sci-fi.
The idea is really to use technology...
...to get away with this sort of boring administrative task.
Guests check themselves in.
Touch screen, check in, much the same, put your credit card in.
The same as the airlines, it will bring up your booking and give you a room key.
And meet Yobot.
He'll store your luggage and you don't even have to tip him.
The spacious fourth floor lobby includes the club lounge...
...complete with private cabins and a 7,000-square-foot outdoor terrace.
Dojo, the restaurant, features motorized tables transforming into a dance floor...
...at the flick of a switch.
The rooms or cabins as they're called are small but stylish,...
...and at $200 a night, you get pretty much everything you need,...
...plus a moving bed.
Now, if you're a big spender, there's a place for you too:...
...a two-bedroom VIP suite for a cool $1,500 per night.
There's a table here that converts to a pool table, a fireplace.
This is our rotating round bed.